can we zoom in and talk about
covid19 virus sure i don't know what
your preferred name is but well
right the virus is sars cov2 which is
hard it's long right and then covid19 is
the disease so you could say the virus
of covet 19 that's fine the virus will
cover 19. but for the purpose of this
conversation we'll every once in a while
just say covid it's fine no problem
what is this virus
from i don't know how many ways we can
talk about it i think from a basic
structural
like the the varian
structure
biological structure perspective what is
it
what are its variants can you describe
the basics the important characteristics
of the virus so viruses are classified
by humans just to make it easier to keep
track of them right
so this is a coronavirus which is
because when they were first
discovered
i think the first ones were animal
coronaviruses
they looked at them in the electron
microscope and it looked like the solar
corona and that's all there is to it and
i have to say that
early in the outbreak the the place with
the highest cereal positivity in the u.s
for a while 68
was a working-class neighborhood in new
york city called corona
can you can you beat that right that's
crazy yeah so coronaviruses they have
membranes right we talked about
membranes they have spike proteins in
the membrane so they can attach to cells
and inside they have rna
and they are the viruses with the
longest rna that we know of
none other comes close
for some reason
they're able to maintain thirty thousand
so sars cov2 rnas thirty thousand bases
of rna and some of the other coronas are
even longer forty thousand this is a
coronas our family of viruses yes that
included
the
what the the one you mentioned before
version one cesar's kovi one yeah kobe
one and i guess other ones so the first
we first learned of them in animals a
lot of animals pigs and
cows and horses have coronaviruses and
then
in the 60s we discovered a couple of
human coronaviruses that just caused
colds very mild colds that you wouldn't
even think twice about right
and then suddenly in 20
2003 there's this outbreak of
severe respiratory disease in in china
and you know they it started in november
and they didn't tell the world until
february
and
that was really bad because it was
already spreading by the time they
told people about it but
this
went to many 29 different countries only
8 000 people were infected and then it
stopped
and that was the first time we saw
an epidemic coronavirus and it
what they did afterwards is they said
okay
it looks like it came from the meat
markets they have live meat markets in
guangzhou in the south of china
where you can go and pick out an animal
and the guy will
slaughter it for you and give it to you
and then of course there's blood
everywhere and that's how they got
infected and they figured out that
there's this animal called a palm civet
that was the source of virus the palm
civets are shipped in from the
countryside and they the palm civ
somehow in the countryside got it from a
bat so they went looking in caves in the
countryside and they found in one cave
all the viruses that could make up
saurus one
and that was 2012 i would say took about
five eight years after that outbreak so
that was the
first
hint that bats have
coronaviruses that can infect people and
cause problems right
and after that we should have been ready
so didn't they already start developing
vaccines yes so some people started
making vaccines they tested them in mice
but they never got into people
and some people started working on
antiviral drugs
nothing ever came of them because
you know industry
there's no
there's no disease it's gone why should
we make vaccines and drugs and nih in
the u.s you submit a grant and they say
it's too risky there's no none of this
virus around so people were really
short-sighted because i always say we
could have had
antivirals for this
absolutely yeah for sure no question in
fact one the one antiviral that's in
phase three it's called
molnu pyravir
it's the only one that you can take
orally it's a pill it looks really good
that was developed five years ago but
never taken into humans it could have
been ready
so we dropped the ball
and then the next decade 2012 murr's
coronavirus
comes
uh comes up in the arabian peninsula
this comes from camels and infects
people but probably the camels got it
from bats originally some time ago
but that never transmits
from person to person very rarely
every new little outbreak is a new
infection from a camel
so that was 2012 and now here we are
2019 a new outbreak of respiratory
disease in china
and this one really
goes all over the world
where sars one could not it's a
coronavirus you know it's different
enough from sars one that it has very
different properties but it still has a
membrane it still has a very long
rna in the middle and then it still has
the spike proteins that's right what are
the things that are what are the little
unique things
that make it
that much more effective
to make it cause a pandemic of
millions of people as opposed to sars
one yeah well the genome
is
twenty percent different from source one
say and in those bases there's some
there are things that uh make it
different from soros one it binds the
same receptor h2 on the cell surface so
that's remarkable
um it has a lot of the same proteins
they look similar like if you look at
the structure of the spikes they look
similar but there's enough amino acid
differences to to make the biology and
what it is we don't know because
how do you figure that out you need to
study animals because you can't infect
people and the the animal models aren't
great you know for
so the way you figure that out is you
figure out how those differences
what functional
like how the difference in the amino
acids lead to functional difference of
the virus like how it attaches how it
breaks the cell wall exactly and how the
hell do you figure that out like i guess
there's models
of interaction you need uh first you
need an animal of some kind to infect
right you can use mice
people have used ferrets
guinea pigs
non-human primates
all of the above and non-human primes
are very expensive so not many people do
that
and then you can put the virus in the
respiratory tract but in fact
none of them get sick like people do you
know
many people with with kovid get a mild
disease but 20 get a very severe
longer-lasting disease and they can die
from it right no animal does that yet so
we have no insight into what's
controlling that but if you just want to
look at the very first part of infection
and the shedding and the transmission
you can do it in any one of several
animal models ferrets are really good
for transmission they tend they have
nasal structures like humans and they
you can put them in cages next to each
other and they'll transmit the virus
really nicely so you can study that
but the other thing that's important
that we should mention
is how do you manipulate these viruses
so these are rna viruses
you can't manipulate rna we don't know
how to do it
but we dna
because of the recombinant dna
revolution that
occurred in the 70s we can change
dna in any way we want we could change
the single base we can cut out bases we
can put other things in really easily
and
if i may
give it a personal aspect when i went to
mit as a postdoc in 1979 david baltimore
said here's what i want you to do
the the moratorium on recombinant dna
experiments on viruses has just been
lifted i want you to make a dna copy of
polio
and see if you put that in a cell
whether it will start an infection
um
so okay so
i made a dna copy of poliovirus it's
only 7500 bases it's much smaller than
corona
and i took that dna and i put it in a
piece of dna from a bacteria called a
plasmid
and you can grow plasmids and many many
bacteria make lots of them and purify
the dna really easily and i took that
dna
and i sequenced it because we wanted we
didn't know the genome sequence of polio
at the time
and that took me a year by the way
because the techniques we had were
really archaic and nowadays you could do
it in 15 minutes right it's amazing
and i took the dna i put it into cells
and out came polio
so that's the start now since then
everybody has taken that technique and
used it for their virus you can now do
it with source cov2 you make a dna copy
of any rna virus
you can modify it
and you put it back into cells and
you'll get your modified virus out so
that's an important part of
understanding the properties of the
virus let's say in an animal by changing
the virus you're changing a dna copy
you're making the virus then and putting
it into the animal
can you clarify so even in the rna virus
you can take and turn it into
dna yes and then that allows you to
modify it yes
what's that what's that uh mapping well
no no what's the process of going from
rna to dna reverse transcription that's
reversion transcription right oh so you
actually going through the the process
of reverse transcription to do this yes
remember david baltimore and howard had
discovered this enzyme in the 70s they
got the nobel prize for that and when i
went to david's lab at mit
he had the enzyme in the freezer he said
here take this and make a dna copy of
pulse yeah i didn't make the connection
that you can use that kind of thing for
an rna virus
and so that's and then modify it see any
dna virus already exists as dna so you
can modify it
but for rna viruses it was difficult and
so then from that point on for influenza
every other rna virus in coronaviruses
people made dna copies and that's what
they use to modify and ask questions
about what things are doing right what's
this gene doing what if we take it out
what happened can you do the same thing
with uh covid uh is takes rna and then
of course in fact in january 2020 as
soon as the genome sequence was released
from china the
labs all over we're synthesizing this 30
000 base dna
and
getting what can you figure out
without infecting anything just uh
turning into
with the reverse transcription turning
into dna modifying stuff and then
putting it into a cell what can you
figure out
from that oh well you could
let's say you can cut out a gene you see
some genes in the sequence i don't know
what these genes do let's cut them out
and then you could
cut them out of the dna you put the dna
in cells and maybe you get
virus out and you go oh
clearly that gene is not needed
for the virus to reproduce at least in
cells right or maybe you take the g now
and you never get any virus so it's
lethal is there a nice systematic ways
of doing this do people kind of automate
it
absolutely and we
i mean the problem with sars
the covid viruses it's 30 000 bases a
lot of stuff there yeah and
what makes it more difficult is that
you have to it's been classified as a
bsl3
agent
biosafety level three
and so not everyone has a lab that's
capable of doing that so it limits the
number of people who can do experiments
you know some we we're lucky to have a
few in new york city but
not every place has them so you cannot
work
with the virus just out on the bench
like we do with many other viruses you
have to wear a suit and they have to
have special procedures and containment
and so forth so it makes it difficult to
do basic experiments on the virus but
well it's a pandemic there's a lot of
money there's a lot of incentive to work
on it harder and also you don't need to
work on the virus you can take bits of
it and work you could take say just the
spike right and say can we make a
vaccine with just the spike because that
doesn't require bsl3 so yes so if uh
like building a vaccine requires you to
figure out how or antiviral drugs
how to attack various structural parts
of the virus and the functional parts of
the virus right you have to decide on a
target yeah like i'm going to make an
antiviral what am i going to target in
the virus
and
there are a few things that make more
sense than others usually we like to
target enzymes
i don't know if you remember any your
biochemistry but you know enzymes are
catalytic you don't need a lot of them
to do a lot of things so they're
typically in low concentrations in in a
virus infected cell so it's easier to
inhibit them with a drug
and the coroners have couple of enzymes
that we can target
so it's you have to figure that out
ahead of time and decide what to go
after and then you can look for drugs
that inhibit what what you're interested
in it's not that hard to do
there's just something beautiful about
biology
about the mechanisms of biology and i
kind of regret
um falling in love with computer science
so much that i
um
left that biology textbook on the show
and left it behind but hopefully we'll
return to it now because
i think one of the things you learn even
in computer science that studying
biology
and certainly neurobiology
uh you you get inspired
here's a mechanism of incredible
complexity that works really well it's
very robust it's very effective
efficient it inspires you to come up
with techniques that you can engineer in
the machine so that's that's the what
drives a field forward when people
improvise
and come up with new technologies that
really make a difference we have we have
a bunch of those now
you